et techno les technologies géospatiales
contribuer à l'agriculture durable est
également à la sécurité alimentaire une
personne sur neuf dans le monde
souffrent de sous alimentation
est également
cette sous-alimentation cause environ 52
millions de maladie
pour des enfants
avec près de 3,1 millions de décès
d'enfants par an et ceci est beaucoup
plus fréquent dans les pays
sous-développés
presque 45% de de la population des
enfants de moins de cinq ans
alors c'est l'exemple en 2020 au togo
une collaboration entre le gouvernement
togolais et les chercheurs de la nasa
harvest ont permis de créer une
cartographie
permettant de reconnaître
les zones de production agricole les
plus fertiles du togo
donc ici avec une résolution de 1,2 m
pixels
puis une résolution de 10 m pixels
il est possible il a été possible de
calculer les probabilités de rentabilité
agricole dans les différentes zones les
différentes régions du togo donc sur
l'image à votre droite je ne me trompe
pas donc on voit les les zones en verre
qui ont une probabilité plus forte de
rentabilité agricoles et les zones plus
clair on des probabilités
faible avec des faibles des zones de
faible probabilité de rendre un de
rentabilité agricole
les technologies géospatiales contribue
également ou interviennent également
lors des crises sanitaires c'est
l'exemple du choléra c'est aussi
l'exemple avec la crise sanitaire de
l'ebola et tout récemment avec la crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19
également lors de cette crise sanitaire
du coc vide
19 en 2020 la même collaboration le
gouvernement du boulet et les chercheurs
de la nasa abbès ont permis de en
utilisant des images satellitaires de
classifier les zones les plus les zones
économiquement plus vulnérables du togo
afin de répartir plus équitablement
les aides économiques
ces technologies permettent également de
protéger ou bien de préserver
l'environnement et les ressources
naturelles
le programme gm y est et africa de
l'union africaine
lancée par l'union africaine en
collaboration avec l'union européenne
a permis de mettre en place douze
consortium
comprenant 540 quatre institutions
répartis dans 45 pays africains donc ces
institutions utilisent les données
géospatiales et les données
satellitaires pour la protection de
l'environnement et dans plusieurs
secteurs économiques
sur cette image c'est l'image de la côte
l'image de la côte
de la sierra leone nous pouvons
clairement voir les zones les plus
affectées par
le réchauffement climatique
mais également avec une résolution plus
craintes et les possibilités
excusez moi il est possible de voir
et de surveiller les activités millière
dans ces différentes régions
donc ça c'est pour la sierra leone mais
il est également possible d'amener ça à
8 et celle de l'afrique et même encore
plus
les satellites permettent de surveiller
la propagation des incendies de forêt et
également lors des éruptions volcaniques
et alors permettre d'évacuer les
populations à temps pour limiter les
dégâts
les technologies géospatiales
interviennent également lors des
inondations et des tremblements de terre
permettent de reconnaître les zones les
plus affectées
ainsi
permettent aux institutions humanitaires
de déployer les aident à temps
pour les populations
alors parlons d'éducation de qualité et
d'innovation technologique
le programme des nations unies qui
s'occupe des applications spatiales
met en place des institutions un peu
partout dans le monde pour s'assurer de
l'utilisation des technologies
géospatiales pour promouvoir l'éducation
de qualité un peu partout dans le monde
ainsi des experts sont déployés un peu
partout dans le monde pour offrir des
formations aux professionnels et
étudiants
c'est aussi l'exemple du portail afrique
a dit au portal qui est une plateforme
lancée par l'union africaine
en partenariat avec la commission
économique des nations unies pour
l'afrique et aussi en collaboration avec
certaines entreprises privées m les
données géospatiales pour donner accès
aux données géospatiales à tous les pays
africains
alors cette connectivité qu'apportent
des technologies géospatiales
permettent aux étudiants et aux élèves
d'aller approfondir leur formation en
ligne à travers des cours en ligne et
des formations en ligne ce qui conduit à
la recherche et au développement
la recherche et développement en anglais
appelée à andy conduit à l'innovation
technologique
l'innovation technologique conduit à la
prolifération des start up la
prolifération des start up qui a à son
tour a conduit à la digitalisation et
donc contribuer au progrès socio
économiques des pays concernés
depuis janvier
2021 une collaboration entre les
autorités de l'aviation en afrique
asecna est à l'est à l'immense pc de la
france ont permis
d'utiliser
a permis d'utiliser des technologies des
systèmes d'augmentation satellitaires
pour s'assurer la sécurité aérienne dans
l'aviation mais également du pour
utiliser les satellites pour la
télécommunication et pour donner de
l'accès à l'internet
cette technologie géospatiale contribue
également à la création des smart cities
est aussi à la planification urbaine
un exemple simple c'est l'utilisation
des systèmes de navigation les gps par
exemple
aujourd'hui nous pouvons utiliser les
gps parce que c'est aussi grâce aux
satellites
les technologies géospatiales
contribue également à la paix et à la
sécurité
internationales je vais dire évidemment
mais comment
donc les images des satellites
permettent de
détecter les menaces terroristes et
aussi les menaces des conflits entre les
nations afin de parvenir à le contrôler
à temps pour encore une fois limité les
dégâts
elle sait docteur daniel août elle est
professeur om haïti et ancien ingénieur
à la nasa
en 2018 j'avais vu son discours tête sur
l'utilisation des technologies
géospatiales pour le développement
durable ce qui m'a inspiré à vouloir
également utiliser cette technologie
pour contribuer au progrès
socio-économique des pays surtout
émergents
notamment en afrique
en 2021 j'ai eu la chance de la
rencontrer en personne et actuellement
nous collaborons ensemble nous
travaillons ensemble sur un rapport
sur les progrès de dans l'industrie
géospatiale et les progrès sociaux
économiques en afrique
un rapport
soutenu par le panel présidentielle de
l'union africaine de 2021 à 2022 est
présidée par son excellence
le président félix antoine
teasé crédit le président de la
république démocratique du congo
pour terminer
l' agence
spatiale africaine dans les statuts ont
déjà été validées par l'union africaine
et qui sera lancée et basé en egypte
d'ici 2023
portera des programmes et partenariats
autour du secteur géospatiales afin de
contribuer au progrès socio économique
en afrique
comme on les y souvent un anglais de
africa
des agendas total six titres et of the
african union des africains we want soit
en français l'agenda de 1063 de l'union
africaine
la paix que nous voulons merci
[Applaudissements]